so when we have a vector product of two
vectors a cross B equals C let's compute
that vector product in different
coordinate systems so let's begin by
choosing two vectors I hat and jaehun
and notice they're at a right angle and
because there is a unit vector the area
here is equal to 1 and I want to define
K hat to be equal to I hat cross J hat
now our angle theta here was 90 degrees
and so if I use the right hand rule then
I had cross J hat is the right-handed
unit normal is out of the plane of the
figure and so I would write k hat like
that
and notice k hat is out of plane of
figure and because I used my right hand
rule this is what we call a right-handed
coordinate system now there's something
very nice about this cross product
definition notice that there's a cyclic
order i j k is a cyclic order and if you
interchange any two for example J I K
that's anti cyclic and the cross
products satisfy this cyclic rule in
that J cross K hat is I hat and notice j
k i j k i maintains that cyclic order
and k hat cross i hat is j hat k i J
maintains that cyclic order but because
of the way we defined a cross product in
general
a cross B is minus B cross a because now
you're using the opposite direction so
there's a minus sign and therefore any
anti cyclic permutation of these unit
vectors as an example K hat cross J hat
has to be notice I've what's called is
minus I hat
that's anti community of property of the
cross product similarly I had cross K
hat is minus J hat and lastly J hat
cross I hat
is minus K hat and so in fact you only
need to know one and this idea of cyclic
and anti-cyclical to be able to write
down all of the other six so we have one
two three four five six now when you
want to compute the cross products in
Cartesian coordinates for instance it
can be a little bit messy there's going
to be a lot of terms if I write a vector
a as ax I hat plus ay Y J hat plus AZ K
hat and I write a vector B as B X I hat
plus B Y J hat plus B Z K hat and now I
want to compute the cross product of
these vectors to get the new one notice
that there's going to be six terms
because I have I hat well we actually
should say one more thing that I had
cross I hat the angle between these two
vectors is zero there's no perpendicular
projection so that's zero as is J hat
cross J hat K hat cross K hat so of
these nine parts when we take the cross
product three of them
be zero by this rule and we'll apply our
cyclic or anti cyclic rules for the
others and so what we have here let's
just do it in so C equals a cross B and
now let's just go one by one I hat cross
I hat that's zero the vectors
there's no perpendicular part the area
formed by these two vectors is zero
I have cross j hat that's cyclic i j is
plus k hat
so our first nonzero term is ax B Y K
hat i across j hat and now let's do i
hat cross k hat notice that's anti
cyclic I K minus J so our next term is
minus ax b z j hat so there's the first
two and now let's just continue this
process J hat cross I hat that's anti
cyclic so we have we have minus ay y bx
k hat a YJ hat cross bx I hat J hat
cross J hat that's 0 so we have no
contribution there and J hat cross K hat
that is cyclic so that's plus ay Y B Z K
hat and now we have our last two terms K
hat cross I hat that's cyclic so that's
plus AZ B X J hat K hat cross J hat
that's anti cyclic so there's a minus I
hat so it's minus AZ B Y I had and
finally K hat cross K hat well that's
also zero so we have six terms and we
can collect them equal to a X B Y minus
oh let's check this one here we use the
wrong symbol here we have to be a little
bit careful here a Y cross BZ is J hat
cross k hat that's plus I huh so we have
a X B Y minus ay Y B X K hat and now
let's look at the I had terms I'll just
check those off we have a Y be Z minus
AZ B Y I hat and check those two terms
off and lastly we have AZ be X minus ax
B Z so we have AZ be X minus a X B Z and
that's J hat and that's how we calculate
the cross product in Cartesian
coordinates